hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's 4 we're back in the room once
again and actually today you know he is
hiding again I know what is hide again
actually I know exactly what's hiding
again because I was just out at a really
school thing
he won't stop until you find him great
how's that a really cool game I was
playing this game with a really cool
celebrity and his son and I can't say
who it is yet because it's not approved
yet but he was a really cool experience
and I was actually playing the demo with
them both over there over where oh where
I know exactly where and this is really
disturbing because now we're able to
explore more of the house here and I
don't know what's gonna happen if I go
over which way or another whoa is that
mangle okay I didn't come over here the
reason I went over here specifically is
because whoa I didn't know man goes over
here well that's disturbing why's mangle
here of all the people to be here
there's mangle and then over here
there's a special surprise for you guys
right there know what's weird about this
is why why is this kid have another
member of the family
wearing the foxy head that's what's
disturbing about that why is that there
why is that a thing because I noticed
that foxy
okay this is also weird I didn't get
this fun with plushtrap whole control to
use a flashlight
use flash late to stop plus wrap on the
X to skip two hours on the next night I
don't know I don't get how this works
okay so I hear that hope okay all right
so this is how I think it works
ha okay
alright I gotta wait a lot longer what
was that huh oh I see here there
oh he's creeping along
oh yeah yeah I did it okay that's a
whole lesson of what this game is all
about this game is about listening this
game is about listening
unbelievably closely also recklessly
pursuing the people that are trying to
kill you and I started to him that's
awesome that's really cool okay anyway
the full game of this was actually was
actually released so you guys can start
playing it right now as far as I know
but now I have a lot more to worry about
and there's actually a thing where I'm
gonna be very concerned
oh yes going there oh man people were
saying god damnit holy I do not
hear that breathing I don't know what
they're talking about oh my god oh man I
wonder if it's not gonna let me skip two
hours now is it probably not well
alright there you have it then but
what's weird about that is the fact that
I have to listen so closely I literally
can't talk when I'm doing it damn it
starts at 12 that's hardly fair god damn
it
well well damn it damn it damn it damn
it how was I supposed to know like I
don't know what the breathing is I still
have not picked it up oh I hear
footsteps on the right
oh okay I really don't know if these are
actually things oh okay all right okay
all right okay so I think that was the
footsteps okay maybe that was oh man
it's just so hard to play cuz they gonna
listen so closely I mean it's not hard
to play it's hard to talk but it's very
challenging which means that you guys
just kind of got a lot kind of kind of
like be quiet guys you gotta like help
me out here or else I'm gonna die again
horrible ways damn it why couldn't I
keep the skip the two-hour skip would
have been delightful oh boy oh man I
don't want to say anything in case I
missed something and I know I do
anything in case I do something
hi yeah you go back there okay I think
that that sound there is the sound of
the footsteps ooh that might have ended
also okay I think to the left there
might be okay
okay I hear to the right to the right to
the right to the right
hi Serge yeah okay so that is it I hear
the footsteps before you the breathing
and they're more like a crunching like
that exactly like that okay so to the
left to the left to the left to the left
to the left
okay okay gotta go gotta go gotta go oh
god damn it
oh man what's the breathing oh man it's
so hard oh it's so hard oh God huh Oh
what is the breathing what is the
breathing all right let's try it again I
think I just need to take more time on
each door like I need to look down the
hallway either for longer while I can or
wait longer what was that what was that
so now I know what it is now I know what
it is now I can identify it I can beat
it so I do hear the footsteps leading up
to the door and I do know what the sound
is specifically okay okay okay yeah back
off back off please please with sugar on
top please back off take your cupcake
I'll Ram it up I bought it's like a
heart attack every time I run up to the
goddamn door no I wasn't it maybe that
was it that might have been it no that
wasn't it okay I don't think that was it
whoa what was that what was the double
it was the double there
did I hear there was a double there oh
my god
sounds of footsteps
[Music]
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy okay
okay oh man no oh that's what it was
okay alright okay okay okay I'll get out
here okay okay
oh my god I hate this I hate this I hate
this so much
okay oh man
fudgesicles get out of here
flat sickles fudge crap sickles Oh God
oh crap crap sickles oh hey
man that takes a while it takes it like
a second I think that was movement
yeah those movement that was moving I
think I was moving pretty sure tonight
here get out here
Oh get out of here okay okay okay okay I
hate you so much I hate it so much I
hate it so much just get the night over
what was that what was that was that my
door oh man oh man oh man oh man okay
I'm gonna do this too because the could
wear it why am I here am I at Freddy
fazbear's he left without you oh no I
have to stay over at Freddy fazbear's he
knows that you hate it here oh I can't
imagine why you are right beside the
exit if you run you can make it what do
you mean if I run I can make it from
what I can't move
hurry run toward the exit why huh which
way is the exit
no don't you remember what you saw the
exit is the other way hurry and leave
well I want to huh what did I see what
did I see what did he see
it's too late hurry the other way and
find someone who will help you know what
will happen if he catches you holy crap
oh my god you can find help if you get
past them you have to be strong get up
tomorrow is another day oh crap fun with
plushtrap well this isn't gonna matter
still gonna have to go through the whole
goddamn thing I don't like this
yes okay I did that okay all right so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I will see you in ninety three very soon
for me right now
so thanks again everybody and as always
I will see you in the next video
[Music]